Graeme grew up in a working class town north of England. And when he was 11 or 12, his family moved into one of the first houses in a new development that was being built. It was kind of hitting the jackpot for him at that age. Because all around everywhere were homes under construction, which-- I remember this from construction sites in our neighborhood when I was a kid-- was so incredibly fun.
Graeme 在英格兰北部的一个工人阶级小镇长大。当他 11 或 12 岁时，他们全家搬进了正在开发的新小区里的第一批房子之一。对于那个年纪的他来说，这简直就像中了头奖。因为周围到处都是正在施工的工地，而我小时候在自家附近的建筑工地上玩耍时，记得那真的超级有趣。
This became my new playground.
这里成了我的新游乐场。
This is Graeme.
这就是 Graeme。
So I would climb on the scaffolding, do a bit of kind of amateur gymnastics, but also build stuff. And the big thing amongst us kids was lighting fires. And there was tar paper was one thing that burned very nicely.
所以我会在脚手架上爬上爬下，做点业余体操，也会搭些东西。我们这些孩子中间最流行的是点火。有一种油毡纸烧起来非常好。
There was actually all kinds of trouble get into. Bricks and boards to play with and wet concrete to write in. They'd find food the workers left, and cigarettes, which they would smoke. Once they found a porn magazine.
实际上，我们什么捣乱的事都干。玩砖头和木板，在潮湿的混凝土上写字。他们会找工人留下的食物，还有烟，然后偷偷抽掉。有一次他们还发现了一本色情杂志。
And one day, Graeme was there alone, and he had this great idea. He put together a little makeshift seesaw-- or as he calls it, a teeter totter-- with a plank of wood balanced on a brick at the center. He put another brick on one end of the plank. And his idea was to drop something really heavy-- really, really heavy-- onto the other end of the plank from a great height to find out just how far he could send that brick catapulting into space. So to accomplish this, he set up his teeter totter by some scaffolding.
有一天，Graeme 独自在那里，想出了一个绝妙的主意。他用一块木板放在一块砖头中心，做了一个简易的跷跷板。他在木板的一端放了另一块砖。他的想法是，从高处把一个非常重——真的非常重——的东西扔到木板的另一端，看看他能把那块砖弹射到多远的地方。为了实现这个目标，他在脚手架旁边架好了跷跷板。
So I climbed up on the scaffolding. And I carried up this kind of massive piece of curbing stone. I'm guessing around 25 pounds.
于是我爬上了脚手架。我带上去一块巨大的路缘石。我猜大约有 25 磅重。
So you are how high up?
你当时有多高？
Probably at the sort of second floor window level. So what? 15 feet, 12 feet.
大概在二楼窗户的高度吧。所以呢？15 英尺，或者 12 英尺。
He carefully tries to line up the stone directly above the near end of the seesaw below down on the ground. And then he dropped the stone.
他小心翼翼地把石头对准地面上跷跷板近端上方的位置。然后，他扔下了石头。
It landed perfectly. I really had lined this up pretty well. And the brick launched. And the following few moments are probably the most vivid memory I have of my childhood. I was obviously watching to see what the brick would do, because that was the experiment really, to sort of follow that in its journey.
它落得非常准。我确实瞄准得很好。砖头被弹射出去了。接下来的几秒钟可能是我童年记忆中最生动的一幕。我显然是在盯着看那块砖会怎么样，因为那才是实验的真正目的，就是看它飞行的轨迹。
But the brick, it didn't move at all like he thought. He thought it was going to arc into the air like a rocket. Instead, it just seemed to be getting bigger and bigger.
但是砖头并没有像他想的那样移动。他以为它会像火箭一样划出一道弧线飞向空中。相反，它似乎变得越来越大。
I now have an image in my head of this brick just getting larger and larger as it headed right towards my face. I even remember very vividly that the construction of the brick had three circular holes in it. And I can still picture them now as they headed towards me.
我的脑海里现在有一个画面，那块砖正向我的脸直冲过来，变得越来越大。我甚至清晰地记得那块砖有三个圆孔。直到现在，当它们朝我飞来时，我还能清楚地想象出那个画面。
In a kind of slow motion way?
是一种慢动作的感觉吗？
Yes, very much so. I feel like that memory is minutes when obviously, it was just not even a second. So I, I believe, instinctively jerked my head back as this brick came directly towards my face. And I have a very clear memory of the kind of sound and the wind. And even, I believe, the brick, as it flew past me, flicked my fringe.
是的，非常像。我觉得那段记忆持续了几分钟，而实际上它连一秒钟都不到。所以我凭本能猛地把头向后一缩，避开了那块直冲我脸部而来的砖。我有非常清晰的记忆，记得那种声音和带起的风。甚至，我相信，砖头飞过的时候，还撩动了我的刘海。
The fringe of your hair?
你头发的刘海？
Yeah, and it sort of whistled as it went. Even when I throw my dog's ball now, which has a little whistle device in it, that memory comes back to me.
对，它飞过的时候还发出了哨音。现在，即使当我扔我狗的球（里面有个小哨子装置）时，那段记忆也会涌上心头。
This moment was stunning. Like nothing like this had ever happened to him.
那一刻太震撼了。就像他从未经历过这种事一样。
And I remember having to sit down for actually quite a few minutes to recover. I really felt like, probably for the first time, that I was inches away from death. And I remember walking home in some state of shock afterwards.
我记得我必须坐下来缓上好几分钟才能恢复过来。我真的感觉，可能是人生第一次，我离死亡只有几英寸之遥。我记得在那之后，我一路神志恍惚地走回了家。
I used to wonder if the brick had actually hit me and killed me, maybe I'd fallen off the scaffolding or something. I used to wonder whether the crime scene investigators came to look, what would they make of the whole setup? Would they even understand what had happened?
我过去常常想，如果那块砖真的击中了我并杀死了我，也许我会从脚手架上掉下来之类的。我常常想，如果犯罪现场调查员来看，他们会对整个场景作何解释？他们能明白发生了什么吗？
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
You know?
你知道吗？
(LAUGHING) Right. Like you got hit by a brick. Like where did it come from?
（笑）没错。就像你被砖头砸死了。就像它是从哪儿来的？
Yeah. This dead child, who laying in a building site-- there was the teeter totter there, but I even had this sort of vision of what if my body fell forward and destroyed the little structure that I had made down there? And how did I get hit under the chin with a brick? And where's the brick? What the forensics would have made of the whole set up.
是啊。这个死在工地上的孩子……那里放着那个跷跷板，但我甚至有一种幻象，如果我的身体向前倒下，砸坏了我自己在下面搭的那个小结构怎么办？我怎么会下巴被砖头砸到？砖头去哪儿了？法医会对整个现场作何推断。
That's the thing, right? Your own death, that is not bad enough on its own. There's the whole question of the forensics afterwards, what people will make of it. It's weird to think that they'll stare at the scene of your death, look at the objects scattered around you, and get it all wrong, and get you wrong.
就是这样，对吧？你自己死掉本身就已经够糟糕了。还有之后的法医调查问题，人们会怎么看。想到他们会盯着你的死亡现场，看着周围散落的物品，然后把一切都搞错，把你这个人也搞错，这感觉真的很奇怪。
That's the bigger thing, right? The bigger question after you're gone isn't just how it happened, but you, your motives, your state of mind, what to make of you, and your whole life, your good qualities, your bad ones.
这才是更大的事情，对吧？你离开后更大的问题不仅是怎么发生的，还有你，你的动机，你的心态，该如何看待你，以及你的整个人生，你的优点，你的缺点。
Today on our program, we have three stories of people who embark on this kind of forensics for beginners trying to understand somebody's death, bumbling their way through whatever scraps of evidence they can get their hands on, old text messages, handwritten notes, stuff that, frankly, seems so puny compared to the task at hand. WBEZ Chicago, it's "This American Life." I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
今天在我们的节目中，我们有三个故事，讲述了人们如何开启这种“法医入门”，试图去理解某人的死亡，在他们能弄到的任何零星证据中笨拙地摸索，旧短信、手写笔记，这些东西说实话，与手头的任务相比显得如此微不足道。WBEZ 芝加哥，这是《This American Life》。我是 Ira Glass。请继续收听。
So we begin today with a woman whose sister has died and she has questions. The woman's name is Nadia Bowers, and she wrote this to somebody who she thinks might be of help. Quick warning for people listening to the podcast of our show, we've unbeeped some curse words in here. If you prefer a beeped version of today's program, it's at our website. Anyway, here's Nadia.
所以我们今天从一位姐妹去世的女性开始，她心中有很多疑问。这位女性叫 Nadia Bowers，她写信给了一个她认为可能有帮助的人。对收听我们节目播客的听众做一个简短警告，我们在这里保留了一些脏话。如果您更喜欢消音版本，请前往我们的网站。总之，这是 Nadia。
Dear Dealer. Hey, man. What's up? I'm saying "man" because that's my guess as to what you are. All the people blowing up my sister's phone offering and seeking drugs were men-- Brian, Jerry, Eric, and my personal favorite, baby Jesus.
亲爱的毒贩。嘿，老兄。你好吗？我称你为“老兄”是因为我猜你是男的。所有给妹妹手机发信息提供和索要毒品的人都是男人——Brian、Jerry、Eric，还有我个人的最爱，“小耶稣”。
I can make a graph charting the meeting of particular men with misfortune for my sister. It's a safe bet you're just another data point, one among many, part of a pattern. But distinguished because you're the last data point. You're the one who killed her.
我可以画一张图表，记录我妹妹遭遇的那些特定男人的不幸。可以肯定你只是另一个数据点，众多数据点中的一个，是某种模式的一部分。但你比较特别，因为你是最后一个数据点。是你杀了她。
And Dealer-- it just seemed like the right title for you since I don't know your name. We can be informal here, right? You don't have to call me Miss or Mrs. Definitely don't call me Ma'am. My sister called me Nad.
还有“毒贩”——这似乎是你最合适的称呼，因为我不知道你的名字。我们可以随便一点，对吧？你不必称我为女士或夫人。绝对不要叫我“夫人”。我妹妹叫我 Nad。
My sister's Sasha, who I believe you knew. What did you call her? I hope you didn't call her Sash, because that's what a lot of people who loved her called her, and I find it hard to believe that you loved her. Did you know her well enough to care for her, or did you hardly know her?
我妹妹是 Sasha，我相信你认识她。你管她叫什么？我希望你没叫她 Sash，因为那是很多爱她的人对她的称呼，而我觉得你不可能爱她。你了解她到足以关心她吗？还是说你根本就不了解她？
When we were little, we sometimes called one another after the food we give our cats. She was Tender Vittle, and I was Chef's Blend. Did you even call her by her name? Or was it Lady? Or maybe you had a nickname for her like purple, the color of her car, the one she was found in.
当我们小时候，我们有时会用我们喂猫的食物来称呼对方。她是“Tender Vittle”（软猫粮），我是“Chef's Blend”（厨师精选）。你甚至叫过她的名字吗？还是叫她“小姐”？或者你给她起过像“紫色”这样的绰号，因为那是她车的颜色，她就是在那辆车里被发现的。
Keeping with our informal tone, I won't call you Mr. I'll just call you "my man," because that is what you are. You are my man, the one I want to talk to, the one I'm seeking, the only one who knows some very important things about how my sister died. You are quite possibly the last person who saw her alive, and I'm a little jealous. As for me, you don't have to call me by my name. You can just call me "The Sister."
为了保持随便的语气，我不会叫你“先生”。我就叫你“老兄”，因为你就是。你就是我的那位“老兄”，我想交谈的对象，我在寻找的那个人，唯一知道我妹妹是如何去世的一些重要信息的人。你很可能是最后一个见到她还活着的人，我有点嫉妒。至于我，你不必叫我的名字。你直接叫我“姐姐”就行了。
I think about you all the time, almost every day. I feel like I deserve to know you, like I deserve the have at least five minutes of your time, five minutes alone with you. This is me tying you to a chair so we can think about some things together. Are you still alive? I feel like you are, and I'm angry about that. But then if I learned who you were and that you were dead, I might be angry about that too. I think about hurting you. And when I imagine the violence I could commit, it alarms me.
我无时无刻不在想你，几乎每一天。我觉得我有权认识你，我觉得我有权至少占有你五分钟的时间，和你单独待五分钟。这就是我把你绑在椅子上，让我们一起思考一些事情。你还活着吗？我觉得你还活着，我为此感到愤怒。但如果我了解到你是谁，而且你已经死了，我可能会为此感到更愤怒。我想过要伤害你。当我想象我可能犯下的暴力行为时，我被自己吓到了。
It's important to me that you know some things. I want you to see who you messed with, know who you destroyed. Sasha was the valedictorian of her high school class. She studied psychology at Yale. She was bold. I was her apprentice.
让我告诉你一些事情很重要。我要你看看你招惹的是谁，知道你摧毁的是谁。Sasha 是她高中班级的毕业生代表。她在耶鲁大学学习心理学。她很勇敢。我是她的学徒。
She gave me my taste in music. Riding around in her Ford Escort, she'd slip in a cassette, explaining the difference between Funkadelic and Parliament. One of my most prized possessions is a cassette tape where we taped ourselves on mushrooms sitting in my room. I was a senior in high school. She was home from college for Christmas vacation.
她培养了我的音乐品味。坐在她的福特 Escort 里，她会放进一盘磁带，解释 Funkadelic 和 Parliament 之间的区别。我最珍贵的财产之一是一盘磁带，上面录着我们吃下蘑菇后坐在我房间里的谈话。那时我是高三学生。她圣诞假期从大学回家。
Stop it. What are laughing at?
别闹了。你在笑什么？
Nothing.
没什么。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
That's Sasha asking me what I'm laughing at. "Nothing," I tell her. We stared as my grandmother's watercolors on my wall started to blur.
那是 Sasha 在问我在笑什么。“没什么”，我告诉她。我们盯着墙上祖母的水彩画，看着它们开始变得模糊。
Oh my God. It's like-- you know what it looks like right now? It really looks like it's like all these different planes, like these different [? dominions. ?]
噢，天哪。这就像——你知道它现在看起来像什么吗？它看起来真的很像是由许多不同的平面组成，就像这些不同的 [？领域？]。
We burned Nag Champa incense and cracked ourselves up about things we called social experiments. These were basically fantasies about ways we could be completely inappropriate in situations where certain contained behavior was expected, like the public library.
我们烧着 Nag Champa 熏香，对一些我们称之为“社会实验”的事情笑得前仰后合。这些基本上是关于我们如何在人们期望某种克制行为的情况下完全不合时宜的幻想，比如在公共图书馆里。
And if you [INAUDIBLE] like the library, and I pulled all the books off the shelves.
如果你 [听不清] 像图书馆那样，我把书架上的书全拉了下来。
I [INAUDIBLE] like-- [SCREAMING]
我 [听不清] 像—— [尖叫]
That's me screaming.
那是我在尖叫。
Strange, they're like weirding out or something. Like what are doing? What are you doing? What do you mean? Huh? Huh?
真奇怪，他们好像被吓到了或者什么。就像你们在干什么？你在干什么？你什么意思？啊？啊？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
When I listen to the tape, I hear a self-assured Sasha. She's in control. I'm her little sister, overjoyed to have her full attention, trying to impress her with my wisdom, and also be her court jester. Sasha tells me a story about this horse she knew that she called a total bitch.
当我听那盘磁带时，我听到的是一个自信的 Sasha。她掌控着一切。我是她的小妹妹，因为拥有她全部的注意力而欣喜若狂，试图用我的智慧给她留下深刻印象，同时也是她的宫廷小丑。Sasha 给我讲了一个她认识的马的故事，她称那匹马为彻头彻尾的婊子。
She's just full of snot.
它简直是个鼻涕虫。
--not safe to have around people. And then this girl from the Special Olympics showed up in the barn and threw her arms around the horse's neck, and the horse stayed calm.
——不适合和人待在一起。然后这个特奥会的女孩出现在马厩里，双臂环抱住马的脖子，那匹马竟然保持了冷静。
It was like right on her shoulder, and everybody was like [GASPS] waiting for it to take a bite out of this chick. And it was like she knew. She just like sat there.
它就在她肩膀旁边，所有人都 [喘息] 等着它咬那个女孩一口。但它就像知道一样。它就坐在那里。
Did she bite people?
它咬人吗？
Yes.
是的。
Oh, yeah. That's why it was so cool that she didn't.
噢，是啊。所以它没有咬人真是太酷了。
Right! [LAUGHS] You idiot. [LAUGHS] Oh.
对啊！[笑] 你这白痴。[笑] 噢。
That is so--
真是太——
I bet she did kind know that this wasn't the right time to be an asshole.
我打赌它确实知道现在不是当混蛋的时候。
Is there ever a good time?
什么时候才是当混蛋的好时候？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
No, I didn't--
不，我没——
"Is there ever a good time to be an asshole?" I'm asking her.
“什么时候才是当混蛋的好时候？”我在问她。
I've done the math. And as of March 11, 2018, at 6:49 PM, I have lived longer than my sister. I have walked the earth more seconds than my big sister, who was born 2 and 1/2 years before me. This does not make sense. You have knocked the universe off course.
我算过了。截至 2018 年 3 月 11 日下午 6:49，我活的时间已经比我姐姐长了。我在这地球上行走的秒数已经超过了我的姐姐，她比我早出生两年半。这根本说不通。你把宇宙撞离了轨道。
My husband would say, "Take it easy, Encyclopedia Brown," as he watched me walk around with her phone trying to reconstruct her last days, reading texts, listening to messages, making notes. Trying to figure out who you are, my man. I was hoping to finally understand the part of her life that she refused to share with me at the end.
我丈夫会说，“放轻松点，Encyclopedia Brown（少年侦探）”，看着我带着她的手机到处走，试图重构她最后的日子，阅读短信，收听留言，做笔记。试图弄清楚你是谁，我的老兄。我希望最终了解她生命中拒绝在我面前分享的那部分。
It infuriated me that she kept getting texts after she died, like this one from Brian. "Hey, any of the shirts around?" My hand shaking, I responded, "You should fuck off. This is Sasha's sister, and she died. Go get your drugs somewhere else, you piece of shit." Or this one from Franky, "Any news? Got Sleepies." When there was no response, he wrote, "Must be dead." I wrote back to Franky. "Actually, she is dead. Fuck off. This is her sister. You'll have to fucking get your drugs somewhere else."
她去世后不断收到短信让我非常愤怒，就像 Brian 发来的这条。“嘿，还有衬衫吗？”我的手在发抖，我回复道，“你给我滚开。我是 Sasha 的妹妹，她死了。去别的地方买你的毒品吧，你这坨狗屎。”或者 Franky 发的这条，“有消息吗？我有 Sleepies（某种毒品）。”没有回复后，他又写道，“肯定是死了。”我回复了 Franky。“事实上，她确实死了。滚蛋。我是她妹妹。你得去他妈的别的地方买你的毒品。”
So my man, are you one of the guys she talked to and texted with on her last day? Are you the ex-boyfriend who kept harassing her, the one who introduced her to Oxycontin? That guy? Are you the friend who told me how sorry he was that Sasha died, and that it was a hot day, and maybe her windows were rolled up, and she suffocated during a nap in her car? Are you one of those friends I ran into who didn't have the decency to show up for her memorial? One of those people? Were you feeling guilty about something?
所以老兄，你是她最后一天交谈和发短信的那些人之一吗？你是那个一直骚扰她的前男友吗，那个把羟考酮介绍给她的人？是那个人吗？你是那个告诉我你很遗憾 Sasha 去世的朋友吗？那天很热，也许窗户关着，她在车里午睡时窒息了？你是那些没胆量来参加她追悼会的朋友之一吗？那些人中的一个？你是不是对某事感到愧疚？
Here's something that's been eating at me for a while. I read that you actually don't mind when people die from something you were selling because it tells the hardcore users that the high is really powerful. The high of heroin mixed with fentanyl-- fentanyl, which is up to 100 times more potent than morphine, 100 times more potent than the drug given to my father when he was dying from cancer. So a death from this stuff is like a calling card, is that true? Did my sister's obituary bring in business for you?
这里有一件事一直让我耿耿于怀。我读到过你其实并不介意人们死于你卖的东西，因为这告诉核心用户这种毒品劲儿非常大。海洛因混合芬太尼的劲儿——芬太尼的效力是吗啡的 100 倍，比我父亲死于癌症时给他的药物还要强 100 倍。所以死于这种东西就像一张名片，是真的吗？我妹妹的讣告给你带来了生意吗？
I have a friend who's a Jehovah's Witness. And she told me that in the Resurrection, I'll be able to hold my sister like I used to and speak to her like nothing happened. I like this idea, but I can't get myself to believe it. Her body was burned, cremated at 1,800 degrees. I don't like picturing that, but I do.
我有一个朋友是耶和华见证人。她告诉我，在复活日，我将能够像过去那样拥抱我的妹妹，像什么都没发生一样和她说话。我喜欢这个想法，但我无法让自己相信。她的身体被焚烧了，在 1800 度的高温下火化。我不喜欢想象那个画面，但我还是想了。
Aside from my own body, hers is probably the other female body I knew the best. Lean, taut, muscular. She rode horses. She was fearless, always wanting to ride the ones that were trouble. She could lose her saddle and gallop at a flat run like a wild woman, gripping the horse's mane with her hand. Her leg muscles were iron cables. She used to put me in the vise, a move inspired by our love of the WWF wrestlers. She would wrap her brawny legs around me and squeeze until I almost couldn't breathe.
除了我自己的身体，她的身体可能是我最熟悉的另一个女性身体。瘦削、紧绷、肌肉发达。她骑马。她无所畏惧，总是想骑那些难驯的马。她可以丢掉马鞍，像个野女人一样平地飞奔，用手紧紧抓住马鬃。她的腿部肌肉像铁缆一样。她过去常把我锁在绞刑架里，这是受我们对世界摔角联合会（WWF）选手的热爱所启发。她会用她结实的腿紧紧缠住我，挤压到我几乎无法呼吸。
My mother always called Sasha "the daughter with a bleeding heart." At one point when she was working in New Haven, you would walk down the street with her, and she knew all the homeless people by name. If you were driving with her, she would jerk the car to the side of the road, get out, leaving the car door swinging open, and call to the man or woman to see if they were OK, if they needed anything. That was her life's work.
我母亲总是叫 Sasha “有着一颗流血之心的女儿”。有一次她在纽黑文工作时，你和她走在街上，她能叫出所有无家可归者的名字。如果你开车和她在一起，她会猛地把车停在路边，下车，车门开着也不管，然后呼唤那个男人或女人，看他们是否还好，是否需要什么东西。这就是她毕生的工作。
She was actually a clinical social worker with two master's degrees in social work and public health. For the last five or so years of her life, she had trouble keeping jobs. She had trouble committing to anything.
她其实是一名临床社会工作者，拥有社会工作和公共卫生的两个硕士学位。在她生命的最后五年左右，她很难保住工作。她很难承诺任何事情。
"The daughter with a bleeding heart." Her autopsy report says that her heart weighed 360 grams. When I had to identify her body, the edges of the sheet she lay on were pink from her watered down blood, the watered down blood of her compassionate, bleeding heart. They should have cleaned up better, cleaned her up better. Though I caught myself thinking how perfect her eyebrows were.
“有着一颗流血之心的女儿”。她的尸检报告说她的心脏重 360 克。当我不得不认领她的尸体时，她躺着的那块床单的边缘被她稀释的血液染成了粉红色，她那富有同情心、流血的心脏流出的稀释血液。他们应该清理得更好些，把她清理得更好些。尽管我发现自己在想她的眉毛有多完美。
How old are you? Were you my sisters age? Younger? Did you know she was 44? Maybe that seems old to you, but it's not. She looked older since she started using.
你多大年纪？你和我妹妹同岁吗？更小？你知道她 44 岁吗？也许这对你来说看起来很老，但其实不是。自从她开始吸毒后，她看起来老多了。
But before, before, my man, she was gorgeous, sexy. She probably met you at your place, or the Taco Bell parking lot in her filthy car, baseball cap, picked at skin, too much eyeliner. So maybe you could never imagine that, but she was. Ask anyone who knew her.
但在那之前，老兄，她可是绝色，性感。她可能是在你那里，或者在 Taco Bell 的停车场里，戴着棒球帽，皮肤上有抓痕，眼线画得太浓，在那辆肮脏的车里遇见了你。所以也许你无法想象，但她确实是。问任何认识她的人吧。
Ask the multitude of men who knew her. Ask the ones I would like to line up against a wall execution style and actually execute. Ask her first mind fuck of a boyfriend at age 14, and the obsessive one that followed in high school. Ask the professors, married men, random men, apparent friends, the one who first gave her crack then Oxycontin. Ask her coach who slept with the young women on his team and pulled her into a coke-fueled party scene while she was still a teenager. He denies all this today.
问问那些认识她的无数男人。问问那些我想让他们排成一排执行枪决，并且真的执行的人。问问她在 14 岁时第一个玩弄她感情的男朋友，以及高中时期那个偏执的男人。问问那些教授、已婚男人、随机男人、所谓的“朋友”，那个第一次给她强效冰毒然后是羟考酮的人。问问她的教练，他和队里的年轻女性睡觉，并在她还是个青少年时把她拉进了一个可卡因派对现场。他今天否认了所有这一切。
I find myself fixated on the men. They circle her memory like these loser, dead beat ghosts or something. How dare they have the nerve to be alive.
我发现自己对这些男人念念不忘。他们像失败者、死皮赖脸的鬼魂一样盘旋在她的记忆里。他们怎么敢还有脸活着。
A year after Sasha died, after visiting her grave on a summer day, I drove through the center of our hometown. By the town green, there was a cluster of boys and girls not yet high school age. The boys were on their BMX's doing tricks, riding down a little hill. The girls were all clumped together watching these young peacocks strut their stuff, knowing their job was to sit there and be impressed. They were nearly silent, whispering among themselves while the boys were having all the fun. I drove by them and shocked myself by rolling down the window and yelling, "Girls, get a backbone. They are not that cool." I worried what my sister's death was doing to me.
Sasha 去世一年后，在一个夏日参观完她的坟墓后，我开车穿过了我们家乡的中心地带。在镇中心的草坪旁，有一群还没上高中的男孩女孩。男孩们在骑着小轮车玩特技，从一个小坡上骑下来。女孩们簇拥在一起看着这些年轻的孔雀卖弄风情，知道她们的工作就是坐在那里表示钦佩。她们几乎保持沉默，在彼此耳边低语，而男孩们则玩得兴高采烈。我开车经过她们时，竟然做出了惊人的举动：摇下车窗大喊：“女孩们，挺起腰杆来。他们没那么酷。”我担心我妹妹的死对我造成了什么影响。
What was your day like today, your day as a dealer? There's so much heroin and fentanyl on the streets these days, I'm pretty sure you're crushing it, as the kids say. On the radio, I heard the chief medical examiner for Connecticut actually get choked up about how they need to build new buildings just to keep up with all the dead bodies from overdoses. A grown man who sees dead bodies for a living cried. You, my man, are powerful. Is that how you feel?
你今天过得怎么样，你作为毒贩的一天？现在街上有这么多海洛因和芬太尼，我很确定你发财了，正如孩子们所说的。在收音机里，我听到康涅狄格州的首席法医竟然因为他们需要建造新大楼来应对所有死于用药过量的人而哽咽。一个以看尸体为生的成年男人竟然哭了。你，我的老兄，真是很有权势。这就是你的感觉吗？
A few days before she died, Sasha sent me a silly text. There had been an incident about a week and a half before at my mother's house, where she had been hosting a cookout for friends. Sasha showed up in bad shape, slurring her words, fighting off drowsiness. I forbade her to use some combination charcoal gas grill because I thought she was going to blow us all up. There was a fight. She felt wrongly accused and was crying a lot. I tried to get her to talk to me about what was really going on, and that went nowhere. My mom confronted her with some hard evidence, a text I saw ding on to her phone.
在她去世前几天，Sasha 给我也发了一条愚蠢的短信。大约一周半前在我母亲家发生了一起事件，她当时正在为朋友举办户外烧烤。Sasha 出现时状态很糟糕，说话含糊不清，努力抗拒着睡意。我禁止她使用某种炭火燃气烧烤架，因为我觉得她会把我们大家都炸上天。发生了一场争吵。她觉得自己被冤枉了，哭得很厉害。我试图让她和我谈谈到底发生了什么，但没谈成。我妈用一些确凿的证据质问她，那是我看到她手机上弹出的一条短信。
Sasha did this thing when she knew she was caught. She would stare hard into your eyes while she sized you up. What did you know for sure? What could she convince you of? What could she get away with admitting without completely throwing herself under the bus? Eventually she just sort of faded away into the next room, trying to clear the table, but knocking things over instead.
Sasha 在知道自己被抓包时会做一件事。她会死死盯着你的眼睛，衡量你。你知道什么？她能说服你什么？她能承认什么而不至于把自己完全推下火坑？最终她只是默默地走进了隔壁房间，试图收拾桌子，却把东西碰倒了。
I was still holding a grudge about it, but I was happy to get her innocuous text asking if I remember the drawing in our middle school French books that went with the word "faible," meaning "weak." It looked like a man with no bones making a face like he had just eaten something distastefully bland. Growing up, my sister delighted in imitating the man, "Faible," and making me crack up. She did it so often, it was such a staple in our repertoire, that I thought it was odd that she would even have to ask if I remembered.
我当时还在因为那件事记恨，但我很高兴收到她那条天真的短信，问我是否还记得我们中学法语课本里那个和单词“faible”（意为虚弱）配套的绘图。那看起来像一个没有骨头的男人，做出一副好像刚吃了什么令人不快且平淡的东西的表情。成长过程中，我妹妹很乐于模仿那个男人，发出“Faible”的声音，逗得我大笑。她做过太多次了，这是我们保留节目中的一个支柱，所以我当时觉得她竟然还需要问我记不记得这件事，这很奇怪。
But this was our pattern. There would be an incident. Then after things subsided, she would reach out, and we would both be happy to not have to deal with the larger issue. But each time, I knew I was being roped into denial. I was less willing this time, and I held out on writing her back. I wanted to punish her a little more, show her I wasn't a pushover. But this thought came to me strongly. "You don't want that to be the last text she ever sends you. Read the subtext. She may need you. And you need to let her know that you love her." I never texted Sasha back. I waited too long.
但这就是我们的模式。会有一次冲突。然后在事情平息后，她会主动联系，我们俩都会很高兴不必处理那个更大的问题。但每一次，我都知道自己被拖入了拒绝面对现实。这一次我不太愿意，我没有回信。我想再惩罚她一点，向她展示我不是好欺负的。但这个念头强烈地涌上心头。“你不会想让那成为她发给你的最后一条短信的。读懂言外之意。她可能需要你。你需要让她知道你爱她。”我从来没有给 Sasha 回短信。我等得太久了。
After she died, I looked at the texts in her phone from the night of that cookout, the night we fought about whether she was on drugs. She wrote a friend, "How do I not hate my sister? My family truly hates me. I don't want to talk anymore." Her friend wrote back, "Damn. Nadia, the fucking narc."
她去世后，我查看了她手机里那场烧烤之夜的短信，那个我们争论她是否吸毒的夜晚。她写给朋友说，“我怎么才能不恨我姐姐？我的家人真的恨我。我不想再谈了。”她的朋友回复说，“该死。Nadia，那个他妈的缉毒警察。”
Seeing the word "hate" in association with me knocked the wind out of me. I wanted to yell at her, "No, you've got it all wrong. I'm the one who loves you, not those people." But by the time I read that, she was already dead.
看到“恨”这个词与我联系在一起，让我感到透不过气。我想对她大喊，“不，你完全错了。我才是那个爱你的人，不是那些人。”但当我读到那条信息时，她已经死了。
On July 31, 2015, the day she died, she had just seen her drug counselor. After our dad died and her addiction blossomed, he became the father figure in her life. She was working in his garden. Toward the end of her life, she created gardens for people just because she loved it. It gave her a place to put her anxiety, her manic tendencies. He called to her saying he had to go and was she OK. She waved him on, "I'm fine. I'm fine." This was maybe 3:30 PM. I'm glad that she saw her counselor that day. They loved one another very much.
2015 年 7 月 31 日，她去世的那天，她刚见过她的毒品咨询师。父亲去世、她的成瘾问题加重后，他成了她生命中的父亲形象。她在帮他打理花园。在她生命的最后阶段，她为人们建造花园仅仅是因为她喜欢。这给了她一个安放焦虑、躁狂倾向的地方。他叫她，说他必须走了，问她还好吗。她挥手让他走，“我很好。我很好。”这大概是下午 3:30。我很高兴她那天见了她的咨询师。他们非常爱对方。
At 4 o'clock, she has a 47 second outgoing call to Alan. At 4:02 there is an incoming call from Alan for 54 seconds. At 4:08, she calls Gary for one minute, then Gary calls her back at 4:20, and they talk for 42 seconds. At 4:27, she calls Gary again, and they talk for 41 seconds. At 4:39, she has an outgoing call to Tim for one second. At 4:40, she has a call out to Jerry for one minute.
下午 4 点，她给 Alan 打了一个 47 秒的去电。4:02 有一个来自 Alan 的 54 秒来电。4:08，她给 Gary 打电话打了一分钟，然后 Gary 在 4:20 回电，他们谈了 42 秒。4:27，她又打给 Gary，谈了 41 秒。4:39，她给 Tim 打了一个一秒钟的去电。4:40，她打给 Jerry，谈了一分钟。
Are you Alan, Gary, Tim, Jerry? Were you the last one to talk to her? Did you see her too? Were you with her? Both her windows were rolled down. Had someone been in her passenger seat? Were you with her when she died, and you got scared and ran? Tell me what were her last moments like? What was she saying before? Did you watch her die?
你是 Alan、Gary、Tim 还是 Jerry？你是最后一个和她说话的人吗？你也见过她吗？你和她在一起吗？她的两扇车窗都摇下来了。副驾驶座上有人吗？她死的时候你和她在一起吗，然后你害怕了就跑了？告诉我她最后的时刻是什么样的？她之前说了什么？你看着她死去的吗？
My mother worries that she wanted to die, but I don't think so. How long have you been cutting heroin with fentanyl? I don't think Sasha saw it coming. You sucker punch people, you know? She had meetings coming up written in her day book about possible work. She was trying. In an email reconnecting with a beloved former colleague two days before she died, she said, "Hi. Surprise, surprise. Rumors of my death have been greatly exaggerated. LOL."
我母亲担心她想死，但我不这么认为。你掺杂芬太尼的海洛因卖多久了？我不认为 Sasha 预料到了这一点。你这是搞偷袭，你知道吗？她在日记里记着接下来要参加关于可能工作的会议。她在努力。在去世前两天写给一位心爱的同事并重新建立联系的一封邮件中，她说，“嘿，惊喜，惊喜。关于我死亡的传言被严重夸大了。哈哈。”
Her autopsy says 6:54 PM as the time of death. Sometime between 4:40 and 6:54, Sasha inhaled the drugs that killed her. She hated needles. She was found in her car in the parking lot of a seafood restaurant off I-95. The detective on the scene happened to be an old high school friend. He told me that he thought she had probably used, felt sleepy, and needed to pull over.
她的尸检报告说死亡时间是下午 6:54。在 4:40 到 6:54 之间的某个时间，Sasha 吸入了杀死她的毒品。她讨厌针头。她被发现死在 I-95 公路旁一家海鲜餐厅的停车场里。现场的侦探恰好是我的一位老高中同学。他告诉我，他认为她可能用了药，感到困倦，所以需要停车。
The restaurant is on the water. I was happy that maybe she was seeing water in those last moments. There's an off track betting place next to the restaurant with galloping horses painted on it two stories high. Maybe she saw the horses. I just wonder if she knew what was happening, or did she really just think she was going to take a little nap? I don't want her to have known what was happening. I don't want her to have been scared.
那家餐厅在水边。我很高兴她在最后的时刻可能看到了水。餐厅旁边有一个场外投注站，上面画着两层楼高的奔马。也许她看到了马。我只是想知道她是否知道发生了什么，还是说她真的以为自己只是要打个小盹？我不希望她知道发生了什么。我不希望她当时害怕。
If I'm going to be honest here-- am I going to be honest here? Maybe I don't want to believe that you deserve my empathy. I don't want to look you in the eye because you may not look much different than my sister. You may be like her, someone who can't be around their family that much anymore, because pretending is so hard. Seeing Sasha trying to dry the wineglasses we used for Thanksgiving while she nodded out, pretending that she still had one foot in our world, was one of the most heartbreaking things I have seen.
如果我要诚实的话——我要诚实吗？也许我不希望相信你值得我的同情。我不想直视你的眼睛，因为你看起来可能和我妹妹没什么两样。你可能像她一样，是一个无法再和家人待在一起的人，因为假装太难了。看着 Sasha 在感恩节试图擦干我们用过的酒杯时睡着了，假装她的一只脚还在我们的世界里，是我见过的最令人心碎的事情之一。
You may look like that. You may be sick, needing to get high just to maintain some equilibrium. You may have been her friend. I may have even met you. You may have called her Sash. You may have loved her. God help you if you loved her.
你可能看起来就是那样。你可能生病了，为了保持某种平衡不得不吸毒。你可能是她的朋友。我甚至可能见过你。你可能叫过她 Sash。你可能爱过她。如果你们爱过她，上帝保佑你。
To be fair, my sister dealt too. As I was writing this to you, my husband offered me a gentle reminder of this fact. It was mainly so she could use. There's long hand addition and subtraction in the back of her day book with people's initials, how much they owed or paid her, how much she owed and paid in return. It's chump change really, written a few times as "Me, free." Drugs were her pay. This was not high rolling dealing. This was survival.
平心而论，我妹妹也卖毒品。当我写这封信给你时，我丈夫温柔地提醒我这个事实。这主要是为了让她自己能用。她的日记本后面有手写的加减法，写着人们的首字母，他们欠她多少钱或付了多少钱，她又欠了谁多少钱付了多少钱。说实话，那都是些零钱，几次写着“我，免费”。毒品是她的酬劳。这不是什么大额交易。这只是生存。
When my husband reminded me that my sister was dealing too, I quickly defended her. "Yeah, but she never killed anyone." He said again gently, "You don't know that." I was stunned. It's true. I didn't know that. And the fact is she could have killed someone.
当丈夫提醒我妹妹也在卖毒品时，我立刻为她辩护。“是啊，但她从来没杀过人。”他又温柔地说，“你不知道。”我惊呆了。这是真的。我确实不知道。事实是她确实可能杀过人。
My worst fear when she was alive was that she would be driving around high and kill someone. The idea of her killing someone kept me up at night. I often thought about having her followed, so curious I was about what her days were like where she would go. I was once driving to visit her and my mother thinking about how I could spy on her when there was a traffic slowdown on I-95 a few exits away from our hometown. On the radio, they said there was an accident up ahead. My mind went to my sister. Had she caused it?
当她还活着时，我最担心的就是她会在吸毒后开车并杀死某人。她杀死某人的想法让我彻夜难眠。我经常想让人跟着她，因为我太好奇她的一天是怎么过的，她会去哪里。有一次我开车去探望她和母亲，想着我怎么能监视她时，在离我们家乡几个出口外的 I-95 公路上出现了交通拥堵。收音机里说前面出了事故。我的脑海里出现了我妹妹。是她造成的吗？
I pulled up in the traffic jam right behind a purple car. I gasped. It was Sasha. Here was my chance to play detective. She moved to the right lane, and the middle one I was in began to pull forward. I was at risk of being seen, so I decided to not try to hide. I pulled up next to her, ready to make a stupid face and stare at her until she felt my presence. To my horror, she looked half asleep. Her head was back, her eyes at half mast. I couldn't believe she was able to drive a car. My heart started racing and I pulled in behind her as if that might shield other cars from her.
我把车开进车流堵在了一辆紫色轿车后面。我倒吸一口凉气。是 Sasha。这就是我当侦探的机会。她换到了右车道，我所在的中间车道开始向前移动。我有被发现的风险，所以我决定不隐藏了。我开到她旁边，准备做一个愚蠢的鬼脸，盯着她直到她感觉到我的存在。令我恐惧的是，她看起来半睡半醒。她的头靠后，眼睛半睁。我无法相信她竟然能开车。我的心跳加速，我开到她后面，好像那样能保护其他车免受她的伤害。
I followed her all the way home to her house, trying to steer her car with my body like a bowling ball headed for the gutter. She was still living in her own place with an ex-boyfriend turned best buddy, not yet evicted, and forced to live with my mother during the last year of her life. I pulled into her street and watched her drive into her driveway. I wanted to follow her in, barge into the apartment that she never let me enter. But I froze, because I didn't know what I'd do once I was inside. Deliver some Joan of Arc, Oprah, Hulk Hogan speech? Like she'd go for that? So I did nothing. I told myself "She's going to an outpatient clinic. She has a therapist, a drug counselor, all these professionals helping her."
我一路跟着她回到家，试图用我的身体像个滚向阴沟的保龄球一样引导她的车。她当时还和前男友变身死党住在自己的公寓里，还没被驱逐，也没有在生命的最后一年被迫和我母亲住在一起。我开进她的街道，看着她开进车道。我想跟着她进去，闯入那个她从不让我进入的公寓。但我僵住了，因为我不知道进去后该做什么。发表一段圣女贞德、奥普拉或绿巨人霍根式的演讲？她会买账吗？所以我什么也没做。我告诉自己，“她要去门诊。她有治疗师、药物咨询师，所有这些专业人士都在帮助她。”
But unfortunately, she also had you. And here's the thing, my man. I need you too. I know that. I know what I'm doing here. Because of you, I get to say, "If it weren't for that guy." Because of you, I don't have to blame her. Because of you, I can nod my head when people tell me there's nothing I could have done. But I don't know if that's true.
但不幸的是，她还有你。问题就在这里，老兄。我也需要你。我知道。我知道我在做什么。因为你，我可以借口说：“如果不是那个家伙。”因为你，我不必责怪她。因为你，当人们告诉我我无能为力时，我可以点头表示赞同。但我不知道那是不是真的。
I did try. My family tried interventions, honesty, confrontation, rejection, love. She once told my parents that out of anyone in the world, she cared most about what I thought of her. I ache at the possibility that if anyone in the world could have saved her, it was me.
我确实尝试过。我的家人尝试过干预、诚实、对抗、拒绝、爱。她曾经告诉我父母，在这个世界上，她最在意的是我对她的看法。我因为这种可能性而心痛：如果世界上有谁能救她，那就是我。
But to save her, I would have had to go to her, live with her, make it my life. I would have had to physically remove her from her life and stand guard at the door holding a shotgun. I would have had to somehow wrestle her denial, get her to finally go to her knees and raise the white flag. But I got engaged. I got pregnant.
但为了救她，我必须去她那里，和她一起生活，把这变成我的生活。我必须把她从她的生活中物理移除，并在门口守着，手里拿着散弹枪。我必须以某种方式压制她的否认，让她最终跪下并举起白旗。但我订婚了。我怀孕了。
Today, whenever I tell somewhere about my violent feelings towards you, they inevitably say, "Well, if it wasn't him, it would have been someone else. If it wasn't him, it would have been some other guy." But my question is, why did it have to be anyone at all? Why should my comfort be that there would have been another one? That all we can expect from life is a game of whack-a-mole but with shitty people?
今天，每当我告诉别人我对你的暴力冲动时，他们不可避免地说，“好吧，如果不是他，也会是别人。如果不是他，也会是别的家伙。”但我的问题是，为什么一定要有任何人？为什么我的安慰应该是还会再有另一个？难道我们能从生活中期待的仅仅是一场打地鼠游戏，只不过换成了这些烂人？
I can't accept that because you know what, man? It was you. And yeah, I'm raging at you so I don't have to rage at myself or my sister, to save myself from falling into a sad heap on the ground. So yeah, I'm using you. I don't care. None of this is fair, my man.
我无法接受，因为你知道吗，老兄？就是你。没错，我在对你愤怒，这样我就不必对自己或我妹妹愤怒，以保护自己免于瘫倒在地上变成一堆悲伤的残骸。所以我利用了你。我不在乎。这一切都不公平，老兄。
So fuck you. Fuck you because you're still here and there will never be another her. Fuck you because I will always think about you. You are my dealer now, man. You dealt me a life without Sasha. Because of you, I'm going out to do this alone. And I'll never let you forget that. Yours forever, The Sister.
所以去你的。去你的，因为你还活着，而她永远不会再有另一个了。去你的，因为我会一直想到你。你现在是我的毒贩了，老兄。你给了我一个没有 Sasha 的生活。因为你，我得独自去面对这一切。我永远不会让你忘记这一点。永远属于你的，姐姐。
Nadia Bowers, she's writing a memoir about her sister. Coming up, the problem with having a Facebook account after you're dead that you have never, ever, ever thought about? That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
Nadia Bowers，她正在写一本关于她妹妹的回忆录。接下来，去世后拥有 Facebook 账号但你从来、从来、从来没想过的问题？一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
This is "American Life." I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "The Secret of My Death," stories of people who die and the stuff about them that is hidden, and the stuff about them that is uncovered after their deaths by people on a mission to figure them out. We've arrived at Act 2 of our program, Act 2, "Commento mori."
这是《American Life》。我是 Ira Glass。今天的节目，“我死亡的秘密”，讲述人们死去后那些隐藏的、不为人知的事情，以及在他们死后被一些肩负使命的人所揭开的事情。我们进入了节目的第二幕，第二幕，“Memento Mori（死亡纪念/时刻铭记死亡）”。
Is that act title too obscure? I was hoping it would be a kind of a play on "Momento mori," which is like a moment of awareness of one's own death. But even I know maybe that's too obscure. But anyway, a lot of this story happens in the comments section of Facebook. So you know, commento mori? Anyway, Stephanie Foo explains.
这个幕题是不是太晦涩了？我希望它是对“Memento Mori”的一种双关，意思是意识到自己死亡的时刻。但即使是我也知道这可能太晦涩了。总之，这个故事的很多部分发生在 Facebook 的评论区。所以你知道，“Commento Mori”？不管怎样，Stephanie Foo 来解释一下。
After someone you love dies, suddenly even their most annoying traits in retrospect seem endearing. Blake Burkhart's friend was this guy Dave Maher. They were both comedians in Chicago, met in their 20s in the comedy scene. Blake was drawn to Dave because he was this extroverted weirdo, loud and absurd. He was also a problem drinker and constantly high. He even had a bit about being so stoned he couldn't order food at the movies. And he had this laugh.
在你爱的人去世后，突然间连他们最烦人的特质在回顾时似乎也变得可爱起来。Blake Burkhart 的朋友是这个叫 Dave Maher 的家伙。他们都是芝加哥的喜剧演员，20 多岁时在喜剧圈相识。Blake 被 Dave 吸引是因为他是个外向的怪胎，吵闹而荒谬。他也是个问题酗酒者，总是吸得飘飘欲仙。他甚至有一个段子说他吸太多以至于在电影院点不到吃的。他还有那种笑声。
I remember that kind of bugging me. Like he [LAUGHS] he would just start talking real fast like, "Oh, hoo hoo hoo!" [LAUGHS] It's hard to do an impression. But he'd be like, "Come on, Blakey boy! Oh hoo hoo hoo hoo, come on!" And he'd grab me and shake my shoulders and stuff if he was excited about just the dumbest thing, like a new joke he wrote. [LAUGHS]
我记得那笑声真的很让我困扰。[笑] 他会突然开始很快地说，“哦，呼呼呼！” [笑] 这很难模仿。但他会说，“来吧，Blakey 男孩！哦呼呼呼呼，来吧！” 如果他因为什么蠢事（比如他写的新段子）感到兴奋，他会抓住我，摇我的肩膀什么的。[笑]
Dave saw himself as this in your face, brutally honest, iconoclast. But Blake says thinking about it now, he can't really remember any actual instances of Dave being much of a rebel. He just remembers Dave as being disarmingly nice.
Dave 把自己视为那种直面现实、残酷诚实、打破偶像的人。但 Blake 说现在回想起来，他真的记不起任何 Dave 表现得像个反叛者的实例。他只记得 Dave 是那种令人卸下心防的友善。
To me, it was almost a little bit annoying how kind he was, because it made me look bad in comparison. And we were always together.
对我来说，他的善良甚至有点烦人，因为相比之下显得我很糟糕。而且我们总是待在一起。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
But yeah, he would go up to people that he had only met once or twice and say like, "Hey, how's it going? How are you today?" And you could tell he really meant it.
但没错，他会跑去跟那些只见过一两次的人说，“嘿，怎么样？今天过得好吗？” 你看得出来他是真心的。
On stage, you could often hear this earnestness in Dave's comedy, this almost childlike excitement about ridiculous stuff.
在舞台上，你经常能从 Dave 的喜剧中听到这种真诚，一种对他那些荒谬事情的孩子般的热情。
I heard a song played on church bells recently, you guys. And it just was like-- you know when you just hear something, you're like, oh! Something shifts inside you, you know? And I heard this song, and I just want to do my best to replicate it to see if it affects you guys in the same way, OK? Cool. Ding dong, ding dong. Ding, ding, ding, ding, bong, bong, bong, bong, bing--
你们，我最近听到一首歌是用教堂钟声演奏的。就像——你知道当你听到某种东西，你会想，哦！你内心深处有什么东西被触动了，对吧？我听到了这首歌，我想尽我所能复制它，看看它是否会对你们产生同样的影响，好吗？酷。叮当，叮当。叮，叮，叮，叮，蹦，蹦，蹦，蹦，冰——
That's a recording of a set Dave did on October 10, 2014.
那是 Dave 在 2014 年 10 月 10 日的一场表演的录音。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Twelve days later, Blake got a call that said Dave was in a coma. It was sudden. Dave had been a diabetic, and somehow, his blood sugar had gotten so high that his body shut down. His kidneys were failing. Blake visited him in the hospital. It was jarring.
十二天后，Blake 接到一个电话说 Dave 昏迷了。这很突然。Dave 是糖尿病患者，不知何故，他的血糖升得太高，导致身体衰竭。他的肾脏功能也在衰竭。Blake 去医院探望他。这让人感到极其不安。
Then after three weeks of doctors trying to jump start Dave's body, they told his family it was probably best to take him off life support. They invited his friends to the hospital to say goodbye.
然后在医生们尝试重启 Dave 的身体三周后，他们告诉他的家人，拔掉生命维持系统可能是最好的选择。他们邀请他的朋友去医院告别。
When I found out he wasn't going to be coming out of the coma and was going to be taken off life support, I just said, "I can't go. There's no way I can see him like that, knowing that I'll never be able to talk to him again."
当我发现他不会从昏迷中醒来并且要被拔掉生命维持系统时，我只说，“我不能去。我不可能那样看着他，因为我知道我再也无法和他说话了。”
So instead, I went to my house, where, at the time, I was living with four other comedians and all friends with Dave. And I said, "I'm going to go home, and everyone should just come over tonight after you go see Dave." We just made a whole night out of it, and just kind of made basically a wake for Dave, and just kind of waited for the news of him officially passing.
所以我去了自己家，当时我和另外四位喜剧演员住在一起，他们都是 Dave 的朋友。我说，“我回家了，大家都应该在去看过 Dave 后今晚过来。” 我们整晚都在聚会，基本上为 Dave 举行了一个守灵仪式，只是等待他正式去世的消息。
How many people came?
有多少人来了？
Oh, it was at least 50, 60 people.
噢，至少有 50、60 人。
Oh, wow. That's a lot.
噢，哇。那真是很多人。
Everyone knew Dave was going to be taken off life support that night. And finally, a Facebook post confirmed it. "Rest in peace, Dave Maher." Then his 1,700 Facebook friends began to post eulogies of him to his Facebook wall.
每个人都知道 Dave 那晚要被拔掉生命维持系统。最后，一条 Facebook 动态确认了。“安息吧，Dave Maher。” 然后他 1700 位 Facebook 好友开始在他的 Facebook 墙上发布悼词。
"Thoughts and prayers." "I had a gigantic crush on Dave," one admitted. Another said, "Let's all be the most Dave Maher versions of ourselves." Blake's post kept it simple.
“思念与祈祷。” “我曾经对 Dave 抱有巨大的迷恋，” 一位承认道。另一位说，“让我们都成为最像 Dave Maher 版本的自己吧。” Blake 的动态保持得很简单。
I wrote, "I love you, dude."
我写道：“我爱你，老兄。”
Had you ever told Dave "I love you" to his face?
你曾当面告诉过 Dave “我爱你”吗？
I don't know. I don't think so. When you're faced with actually losing them, you kind of realize it more. Unfortunately, that's how it works, so--
我不知道。我觉得没有。当你面临真正失去他们时，你才会意识到这一点。不幸的是，事情就是这样，所以——
Two weeks later on Thanksgiving Day, there was a post on Dave's Facebook page from Dave.
两周后的感恩节那天，Dave 的 Facebook 页面上出现了一条来自 Dave 的动态。
Oh, man. It was this-- it was-- it's so hard to explain.
噢，老兄。它是那个——它是——这真的很难解释。
"This is Dave Maher. Spoiler alert." You're alive?
“这是 Dave Maher。剧透预警。” 你还活着？
Yeah. "Spoiler alert, I'm here."
是的。“剧透预警，我在这儿。”
His friends all whipped out their phones in the middle of their Thanksgiving dinners and started shouting in joy on his Facebook page.
他的朋友们在感恩节大餐中纷纷掏出手机，开始在他的 Facebook 页面上欢呼。
People are saying, "No one celebrates Thanksgiving the way Dave celebrates Thanksgiving." "Dave turned Thanksgiving into Easter."
人们说，“没人像 Dave 过感恩节那样过感恩节。” “Dave 把感恩节变成了复活节。”
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
It turned out Dave's parents never did wind up taking him off life support. They transferred him to another hospital instead. And a couple days later, his dad walked into his room and started talking to him like he had countless times since he'd fallen into the coma.
结果 Dave 的父母最终没有拔掉生命维持系统。他们把他转到了另一家医院。几天后，他父亲走进病房，开始像他陷入昏迷后无数次那样对他说话。
And at some point, perhaps I recognized his voice. My eyes popped open. And I was still intubated at this point, so I had a whole mess of tubes sticking out of my face and attempted to scream. But because I was intubated, it came out silently. But I just mouthed the words, (WHISPERING) "What the fuck?"
在某个时刻，也许他认出了父亲的声音。我的眼睛猛地睁开了。当时我还插着管子，所以我的脸上插满了一堆管子，我试图尖叫。但因为插着管子，我发不出声音。但我只是动了动嘴唇，（耳语）“这他妈是什么情况？”
Dave had been in the coma for a month. He's a type 1 diabetic who had just done an awful job caring for himself. He hadn't paid much attention to what he was eating, drank too much, and he had no way of monitoring his blood sugar because he sold all his test strips for weed money. So he had no idea his blood sugar was skyrocketing, eventually sending him into a coma. The last thing he remembered was puking into a bucket and figuring he must have food poisoning. And then after a month, he woke up in a hospital bed, completely bewildered by the entire situation.
Dave 昏迷了一个月。他是一个 1 型糖尿病患者，而且在照顾自己方面做得很糟糕。他没怎么注意饮食，喝得太多，而且无法监测血糖，因为他把所有的试纸都卖掉去买大麻了。所以他根本不知道自己的血糖在飙升，最终导致他陷入昏迷。他记得的最后一件事情是呕吐进桶里，心想这一定是食物中毒。然后一个月后，他在医院的病床上醒来，对整个情况感到完全困惑。
But the upshot of all that was that he was in this weird situation that some of us fantasize about, that Tom Sawyer thing of being at your own funeral, where you get to hear all the things people say about you. You get to finally find out how you're seen, what people will remember about you.
但这一切的结果是，他处于某种我们幻想中的奇怪境地，那种汤姆·索亚式的参加自己葬礼的体验，在那里你可以听到人们对你说的所有话。你最终能找出你是如何被看待的，人们会记住你什么。
Dave didn't get a chance to look at Facebook for a while. He was still recovering. His hands wouldn't stop shaking, so he couldn't even use his phone. It took another month or so for him to be discharged from the hospital, and that's when he finally decided to read through all of the eulogies people had left on his page, about a hundred of them.
Dave 有一段时间没机会看 Facebook。他还在恢复期。他的手一直在颤抖，所以他甚至没法用手机。他大概又过了个月左右才出院，那时他终于决定读完人们留在他页面上的所有悼词，大约有一百多条。
It was New Year's day after the ball had dropped and everyone went to sleep. He was recuperating in his parents' house, so he went down to their basement and sat alone at the little kitchen island scrolling for hours.
那是元旦，跨年钟声敲过，大家都睡觉后。他在父母家里休养，所以他下到地下室，独自坐在小岛式厨房旁滚动阅读了几个小时。
You know, it got to be 2:00, and 3:00, and 3:30 AM. And I'm just there at this island reading these things from my laptop.
你知道，到了凌晨 2 点、3 点、3:30。我只是坐在那个岛台边，在笔记本电脑上读着这些东西。
One of the first things he spotted right in the middle of all the "I miss you's" was a post from his brother trying to quash the whole thing, written the day after Dave supposedly died.
他在所有“我想你”的中间发现的第一件事，是他哥哥试图平息这件事的一条动态，写于 Dave 所谓的去世后第二天。
I think my family was honestly pretty upset reading some of these things. Like "To friends of David, there seems to be some confusion and unofficial word on David's passing. At the time of this posting, Dave Maher is still with us. Until you hear official word that David has passed, please out of respect for him and our family, refrain from posting about David in the past tense."
我觉得我家人读到这些东西时真的感到很心烦。比如“致 David 的朋友们，关于 David 的离世似乎存在一些混乱和非官方的消息。发文时，Dave Maher 依然与我们同在。在听到 David 离世的官方消息之前，请出于对他和我们家人的尊重，不要使用过去式谈论 David。”
It got 70 likes, three comments. But the Facebook algorithm had buried it. It was overshadowed by all of the comments coming in facilitating the dead Dave narrative. Some of those got twice as many likes. And reading these comments was sort of like you'd imagine. People brought up a lot of memories, things he did, some of which he didn't even remember, funny stories. And he got to see what this life he bumbled through actually looked like from the outside.
那条得到了 70 个赞，三条评论。但 Facebook 的算法把它埋没了。它被所有为“死去的 Dave”叙事推波助澜的评论所掩盖。其中一些得到的赞是它的两倍。阅读这些评论有点像你想象的那样。人们提到了很多回忆，他做过的事情，其中一些他甚至不记得了，有趣的故事。他得以从外部看到他这辈子笨拙行走的样子。
There's pretty good ones in here. [LAUGHS] Oh yeah. This one I had forgotten existed. OK, so this woman writes, "Deep into the late night hour of a crazy, sexy, cool party, I found Dave pounding on a closet door." And then she transcribes this conversation where she says, "What are you doing, Dave?" And I say, "I gotta go to the bathroom." And she says, "That's a closet." And I say, "No, it's not. It's the bathroom, and there are people in there. There are people in there. And they need to get out." And then she says, "I show Dave that it is indeed a closet." And then the last line is me saying, "Just let me knock on the door for a little, and then I'll walk away so that people don't know what I did."
这里面有挺好的内容。[笑] 噢，对了。这个我忘了它存在了。好，这个女人写道，“在疯狂、性感、酷派对的深夜，我发现 Dave 在砰砰敲一个衣柜的门。” 然后她转述了这段对话，她说，“Dave，你在干什么？” 我说，“我得去洗手间。” 她说，“那是衣柜。” 我说，“不，不是。那是洗手间，里面有人。有人在里面。他们得出来。” 然后她说，“我向 Dave 展示那确实是个衣柜。” 然后最后一句是我说的，“就让我敲一会儿门，然后我就走开，这样人们就不会知道我做了什么。”
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
And that's great, man. That's so funny.
这真是太棒了，老兄。这真有趣。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
A bunch of posts perplexed him just because they were so random. There was one from an ex-girlfriend who was appreciative of the fact that he broke up with her inside his car because it was cold outside. One woman said he was a great storyteller and also quote, "unreasonably sweaty."
一堆动态让他感到困惑，仅仅是因为它们太随机了。有一条来自前女友，她很感谢他因为外面冷而在车里和她分手。有个女人说他是个伟大的讲故事的人，并且引用，“特别爱出汗”。
Why?
为什么？
Yeah, absurd, right? Like it's so easy not to include that sentence.
对吧，这很荒谬，对吧？就像不写那句话也很容易。
But as Dave kept scrolling past the funny memories, of course, things got heavier. Many of his friends had been devastated, and they took to Facebook as a form of therapy, pouring their hearts out about their loss. Dozens painted Dave as a devoted friend, the kind of guy who was there with hugs and advice and beer whenever you needed him. And then he got to this one post from a friend that just gutted him.
但随着 Dave 继续滚动翻过那些有趣的回忆，事情变得沉重起来。他的许多朋友都崩溃了，他们把 Facebook 作为一种治疗方式，倾诉着他们对失去他的痛苦。几十个人把 Dave 描绘成一个忠诚的朋友，那种在你需要时带着拥抱、建议和啤酒出现的人。然后他看到了一位朋友的动态，直接让他心碎了。
"Hey, dude. Pretty sure Kit took this photo right before I told you I was going to leave her party in order to go to bed early. And then you made fun of me for doing that. I guess I never thought about this before, but you were totally my best friend in college. Even though you were a senior when I was a freshman, you insisted on treating me and everyone as equals, even though we weren't, dude. You really made me feel so effing cool.
“嘿，老兄。我很确定 Kit 在这张照片拍下前刚告诉我你要离开她的派对去早睡。然后你因为这个嘲笑我。我想我以前没想过这一点，但你绝对是我大学里最好的朋友。尽管我是大一新生时你是大四学生，你坚持把我和每个人都当作平等的人对待，即使我们并不是，老兄。你真的让我觉得自己酷毙了。”
My dumb smile in this photo is 100% genuine because I was so happy to be with you all the time. It wasn't just me who felt that way. Whenever we went to CVS or Walgreens, every employee recognized you and said hello. We've even eaten at Chipotle for free because you have it going on, dude.
照片中我那愚蠢的微笑是百分之百真诚的，因为我很高兴一直和你在一起。不只是我一个人有这种感觉。每当我们去 CVS 或 Walgreens，每个员工都认出你并和你打招呼。我们甚至在 Chipotle 免费吃过饭，因为你有办法，老兄。
Thanks for telling me not to be so hard on myself, and then laughing about how funny that sounded coming from you. Thanks for all the rides home. Thanks for being my best friend. It looks like it's finally your turn to turn in early. You earned it. I'll talk to you later. Duffer." [CRIES]
谢谢你告诉我不必对自己那么苛刻，然后嘲笑从你嘴里说出这种话有多好笑。谢谢你所有的搭车回家。谢谢你成为我最好的朋友。看来终于轮到你早睡了。你应得的。稍后再谈。Duffer。” [哭泣]
That is so sweet.
这太贴心了。
(CRYING) Yeah. [CRIES] Yeah. It's just really sweet. [SIGHS] It's really-- I don't know. It's like so many of these things I didn't remember. Like I don't remember things that way. I don't remember employees at Walgreens all knowing my name. I remember shoplifting from Walgreens and spending the night in jail. That's how I remember this stuff.
（哭泣）是的。[哭泣] 是的。这真的很贴心。[叹气] 这真是——我不知道。就像这些事情中有很多我不记得了。我记得的事情不一样。我不记得 Walgreens 的员工都认识我的名字。我记得在 Walgreens 店里偷东西，然后在监狱里过夜。这就是我对这些事情的记忆。
This was the main thought Dave had going through his eulogies. Even though everyone was being so nice, he thought, "They're all wrong."
这是 Dave 阅读自己悼词时的主要想法。尽管每个人都这么友善，但他心想，“他们都错了。”
I know that people don't really talk shit about someone when they've died, but it's just really tough to like square the image that I have of myself with the way other people talked about me when they thought I was dead.
我知道人们在某人去世时不会真正说坏话，但要让自己对自己的形象与人们认为我死了时所谈论的方式保持一致真的很难。
And that's why reading his own eulogies, it actually made him feel awful. He felt overwhelmed by the complete disconnect between the guy he thought he was and the guy everyone else was talking about. He'd thought that he was at core a bad person, that he took his depression out on people, that he could be insensitive, self-centered.
这就是为什么阅读自己的悼词让他感觉糟糕透了。他对自己认为的那个男人与其他人谈论的那个男人之间的完全脱节感到不知所措。他一直以为自己本质上是个坏人，他把抑郁发泄在别人身上，他可能麻木不仁、以自我为中心。
I put myself in this coma. It was my carelessness, my recklessness, that got me to this place in the first place. And on the one hand, while it's moving to hear that everyone at this wake at Blake's house was so miserable to feel like I had gone, I made these people miserable.
是我把自己送进了昏迷。是我自己的粗心大意、鲁莽，才让我走到了这一步。一方面，听到 Blake 家里守灵的人们因为觉得我离开了而如此痛苦很感人，但我让这些人痛苦了。
That totally makes sense. You were like, "You guys, you're not acknowledging how fucked up it was that I did this stupid thing to you."
这完全说得通。你就像是，“伙计们，你们没有意识到我做这种蠢事让你们受苦是多么糟糕。”
Right. And that's why it was like-- it's very different, the experience with my family. Because my family was pretty aware and they had been hurt by-- in terms of the traditional wreckage that an alcoholic or an addict leaves in their wake, my family suffered a lot of that. And so they weren't effusive when I came back. They were very aware of the ways in which I contributed to the situation.
没错。这就是为什么它和我家人的经历完全不同。因为我家人比较清醒，他们受到了伤害——就酗酒者或瘾君子造成的传统破坏而言，我家人遭受了很多。所以当我回来时，他们没有表现得热情洋溢。他们非常清楚我在导致这种情况方面所起的作用。
So now that everyone was saying he was this wonderful and nice guy, it actually made him feel guilty. Even now years later, it's a burden. Witnessing your own funeral, it actually kind of sucked. Maybe it wouldn't if you stayed dead. The problem is if you have to keep on living. But you know who this didn't suck for? Dave's friend, Blake.
所以现在每个人都说他是这么好、这么友善的人，这实际上让他感到内疚。即使几年后的今天，这也是一种负担。目睹自己的葬礼，实际上感觉有点烂。如果你真死了也许就不会了。问题在于如果你还得继续活下去。但你知道谁没有觉得烂吗？Dave 的朋友 Blake。
Have you ever found his laugh annoying since then?
在那之后你有没有觉得他的笑声烦人过？
No, now it's like music to my ears.
没有，现在它就像悦耳的音乐。
That's so crazy!
这太疯狂了！
Blake got to watch his loved one come back to life. That's really the thing worth fantasizing about. He gets excited just thinking about the day Dave woke up.
Blake 看到了他爱的人起死回生。这才是真正值得幻想的事情。他光是想到 Dave 醒来的那一天就很兴奋。
Yeah, just to relive that moment again and again would be priceless, because that's the happiest I think I've ever felt. I think it just makes me a little happier to be around him every time. It's just like-- I'm just a little happier around him than I could be around any other friend because I know what it's like to also lose the same person.
是的，能够一次又一次地重温那一刻简直是无价的，因为那是我这辈子感到最幸福的时刻。我觉得这让我每次在他身边都更快乐一点。就像——我只是在他身边比在任何其他朋友身边都要快乐，因为我知道失去同一个人是什么感觉。
Dave and Blake both got second chances to love and to be loved. Turns out one's a lot easier than the other.
Dave 和 Blake 都获得了第二次去爱和被爱的机会。事实证明，前者比后者容易多了。
Stephanie Foo is one of the producers of our program. The living Dave Maher has comedy stuff that he would like to share with you at thisisdavemaher.com.
Stephanie Foo 是我们节目的制片人之一。活着的 Dave Maher 有一些喜剧内容，他想在 thisisdavemaher.com 与你们分享。
Act 3, "Funeral for a Stranger." So this last story is about a guy who goes to a funeral for somebody who does not know at all and has to piece together all the stuff you would want to know in that kind of situation. And the guy who did this wrote us an email last summer at the radio show. There was no subject heading in this email. The very first line was a link to an obituary for another guy named Eddie Furlani. Eddie had died a few weeks before. He was young when he died, only 35.
第三幕，“陌生人的葬礼”。最后一个故事是关于一个男人去参加一个他完全不认识的人的葬礼，不得不拼凑起你在那种情况下想要知道的所有信息。做这件事的男人去年夏天给我们电台节目发了一封电子邮件。这封邮件没有主题标题。第一行就是另一位名叫 Eddie Furlani 的男人的讣告链接。Eddie 在几周前去世了。他去世时很年轻，只有 35 岁。
The email began, "Dear This American Life, I'm attaching a quick document that I created Friday documenting some of the thoughts and emotions I had following the funeral of a Navy SEAL. The whole experience was more of an odyssey than I had bargained for." This caught the eye of a producer here on our show, Dana Chivvis. Here she is.
邮件开头是，“亲爱的《This American Life》，我附上一份周五创建的简短文档，记录了我参加完一场海豹突击队队员的葬礼后的一些想法和情绪。整个经历比我预想的更像是一场奥德赛。” 这引起了我们节目制片人 Dana Chivvis 的注意。她来了。
The email was signed by a retired officer in the Navy, a guy I'm going to call Charlie. It's not his real name. The document he had attached to the email was an essay. It was four pages long. He'd written it quickly after Eddie Furlani's funeral. Eddie was a stranger to him, but there was something about the whole experience that seemed to kind of haunt him that led him to write an essay, something deeply emotional. I couldn't tell what it was, so I gave him a call.
这封邮件由一位海军退役军官签署，我打算称他为 Charlie。那不是他的真名。他附在邮件中的文件是一篇文章。有四页长。他是在 Eddie Furlani 的葬礼后匆匆写下的。Eddie 对他来说是个陌生人，但整个经历中有些事情似乎困扰着他，导致他写下了一篇深刻感人的文章。我说不出那是什么，所以我给他打了个电话。
So why did you write us?
你为什么要给我们写信？
I knew you were going to ask this question.
我知道你会问这个问题。
[LAUGHS] Do write radio shows a lot?
[笑] 你经常给广播节目写信吗？
I don't. And I think I wrote you guys one time prior, and that's the only reason why I even knew how to contact you.
不。而且我想我之前只给你们写过一次信，那是我知道如何联系你们的唯一原因。
OK, so maybe Charlie writes radio shows more than most people. I asked him to tell me the story of Eddie Furlani's funeral last summer. The story begins with a random text message from a friend of Charlie's, a guy named Mark. He and Charlie went to the Naval Academy together. After graduation, Charlie went on to become a Naval aviator. He flew medivac helicopters in Iraq in 2007. His friend Mark joined the Navy SEALs, the Navy's special operations forces.
好吧，所以也许 Charlie 比大多数人更经常给广播节目写信。我请他告诉我去年夏天 Eddie Furlani 葬礼的故事。故事始于 Charlie 的朋友 Mark 发来的一条随机短信。他和 Charlie 一起去了海军学院。毕业后，Charlie 成为了一名海军飞行员。他在 2007 年的伊拉克驾驶医疗救援直升机。他的朋友 Mark 加入了海军海豹突击队，即海军特种作战部队。
What was the text that you got from Mark?
你从 Mark 那里收到的短信是什么？
So actually, it started with, a "Good morning." I said, "Good morning. How's Liam, your son?" And his next text is, "Hey, I got a job for you." And that's where my response came back, "Does it involve explosives?"
其实它是从一条“早上好”开始的。我说，“早上好。Liam，你儿子怎么样？” 下一条短信是，“嘿，我有份工作给你。” 我的回复是，“涉及爆炸物吗？”
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
And he says, "Attend the service of a frog man in my absence."
他说，“替我参加一个蛙人的仪式。”
Frogman is a nickname for a Navy SEAL. Eddie Furlani and Mark had been Navy SEALs together. The funeral was going to be in San Diego, and Mark, who lives in Florida, couldn't make it. So he asked Charlie, who lives nearby, to go in his place.
“蛙人”是海军海豹突击队的昵称。Eddie Furlani 和 Mark 曾经一起当过海豹突击队队员。葬礼将在圣地亚哥举行，住在佛罗里达州的 Mark 无法参加。所以他请住在附近的 Charlie 代替他参加。
That was the moment where it was like that moment of decision where I was like, "Well, do I really want to go to a funeral of somebody I don't know in his absence?" If it was anybody but Mark, I probably would have made an excuse.
那就是那个决定时刻，我心想，“嗯，我真的想代替别人去参加一个我不认识的人的葬礼吗？” 如果不是 Mark，我可能会找个借口。
So did you sit there for like a minute or two before you wrote him back thinking of excuses not to go?
所以你在回信之前是不是坐在那儿想了一两分钟，想着不去的借口？
[SIGHS] I'd be lying if I said no. I did think of a few excuses not to go because funerals aren't one of those things that people like attending to begin with, and let alone the funeral of somebody that you don't know, which technically seems a little rude because it just doesn't seem appropriate.
[叹气] 如果我说没有，那我就是在撒谎。我确实想了几个借口不去，因为葬礼本来就不是人们喜欢参加的事情，更不用说参加一个你不认识的人的葬礼了，这在技术上看起来有点无礼，因为这看起来不太合适。
But Charlie wrote Mark back, said, "Send me the details and I'll do it." And then in the swirl of his own life and work and family, he kind of forgot about it.
但 Charlie 回信给 Mark，说，“把细节发给我，我会去的。” 然后在自己生活、工作和家庭的忙碌中，他把它给忘了。
Two weeks later, he woke up and realized it was the morning of Eddie Furlani's funeral. He put on a nice pair of jeans, some nice shoes, and a dark button down shirt. He thought he'd go to the service during his lunch break, catch the eulogy, and then scoot out of there, get back to work. He realized he didn't have any of the details about the service, and he also didn't know anything about Eddie Furlani. So he did some googling and found a Facebook memorial that Mark had set up and a GoFundMe page asking for donations to help support Eddie's family. It mentioned that he had passed suddenly.
两周后，他醒来意识到是 Eddie Furlani 葬礼的早晨。他穿上一条不错的牛仔裤、一双漂亮的鞋子和一件深色扣子衬衫。他想在午休时参加仪式，听听悼词，然后溜走回去工作。他意识到自己没有任何关于仪式的信息，也不知道关于 Eddie Furlani 的任何事情。所以他谷歌了一下，找到了 Mark 设置的 Facebook 纪念页面和一个 GoFundMe 页面，请求捐款以支持 Eddie 的家庭。上面提到他是突然去世的。
In the essay Charlie sent us, he writes, "There are pictures of his three children and the smiling face of Eddie in SEAL training, submerged in mud and smiling and giving a thumbs up with green fatigues on. The date of his passing was listed, and I started googling different military tragedies. Being alumni from a military academy means that rarely is there a military accident where someone I know isn't involved or affected. I found it unusual that I could find no reporting on anything."
在 Charlie 发给我们的文章中，他写道：“有他三个孩子的照片，还有 Eddie 在海豹训练中浸泡在泥里、微笑着竖起大拇指、身穿绿色军服的照片。上面列出了他去世的日期，我开始搜索不同的军事悲剧。作为军事学院的校友，意味着很少有军事事故是我的熟人没被牵涉或影响的。我发现找不到关于任何事情的报道很不寻常。”
You know, at the time, I told myself that he was a Navy SEAL that had died in the line of duty. If it was a major firefight or a conflict, there would be yellow ribbons, there would be parades, there would be flags everywhere, there would be people weeping in the streets if he had died in combat.
你知道，当时我告诉自己，他是因公殉职的海豹突击队队员。如果那是一场重大枪战或冲突，会有黄丝带，会有游行，到处都会有旗帜，如果他死于战斗，大街上会有人们哭泣。
So you knew it wasn't that. You knew it wasn't a battlefield death, but maybe it was an accident
所以你知道那不是。你知道那不是战场死亡，但也许是事故。
Well, I didn't-- you get that little bug in the back of your head because I'm like, OK, well, how did he die? Was it a car accident?
嗯，我没有——你的脑后会有那种小虫子，因为我想，好吧，他是怎么死的？是车祸吗？
The internet didn't shed any light on the mystery surrounding Eddie's death. But anyway, it was the day of the funeral, so Charlie would probably find out what happened there.
互联网没有揭示 Eddie 去世之谜。但无论如何，那是葬礼的一天，所以 Charlie 可能会在那里发现发生了什么。
It's a weird thing being a proxy at a funeral. It reminds me of being a plus one at a wedding, only miserable. You don't know the person who died or their family, so it's hard to have any feelings about it. Like the fact that Eddie Furlani was gone, it hadn't changed the course of Charlie's life at all, just the course of his lunch break, really.
在葬礼上当代理人是一件奇怪的事情。这让我想起在婚礼上当“加一人”，只是很痛苦。你不认识去世的人或他们的家人，所以很难对此有任何感觉。就像 Eddie Furlani 的离开并没有改变 Charlie 生活的轨迹，真的只是改变了他午休的轨迹。
Charlie gets to the chapel late because Mark texted at the last minute and asked him to pick up some flowers for the family, corsages for Eddie Furlani's daughter and widow. As soon as he drives into the parking lot, he notices a woman sitting on the sidewalk dressed in black, attending to a little boy who's having a total meltdown over his pants and how he doesn't want to be wearing them. Charlie recognizes the boy from pictures as Eddie Furlani's son.
Charlie 到教堂晚了，因为 Mark 在最后一分钟发短信让他帮家人带些花，给 Eddie Furlani 的女儿和遗孀带胸花。他一开车进停车场，就注意到一个穿黑衣服的女人坐在人行道上，正在照顾一个小男孩，男孩因为裤子闹得不可开交，不想穿。Charlie 从照片里认出了那个男孩是 Eddie Furlani 的儿子。
When Charlie walks into the chapel, the service has already started, and he's carrying those flowers. So one of the funeral directors intercepts him and asks him if he's the flower delivery guy. Charlie tries to explain awkwardly and in whisper talk because, again, the service has already started, that no, he's there for the service. But no, he doesn't actually know the deceased, and no, he doesn't know the family either. He's just there for a guy in Florida, like as a stand in. The funeral director lets him by, and Charlie finally squeezes into the back row of mourners.
当 Charlie 走进教堂时，仪式已经开始，他带着花。所以一个殡仪馆主任拦住他，问他是不是送花的人。Charlie 尴尬地解释着，低声说话，因为仪式已经开始了，他不是，他是来参加仪式的。但不，他其实不认识死者，也不认识家人。他只是为了佛罗里达的一个家伙代班。殡仪馆主任让他进去了，Charlie 终于挤进了哀悼者的最后一排。
The pews were all full, and the walls-- especially the back of the walls were lined with men in three piece suits that were 6 foot 4, athletically built, wearing sunglasses. I mean, you're clearly Navy SEALs.
长椅都坐满了，墙边——特别是后墙边站满了身穿三件套西装、身高 6 英尺 4 英寸、体格健壮、戴着太阳镜的男人。我的意思是，你显然是海军海豹突击队队员。
People were giving eulogies. In his essay, Charlie writes that it felt odd to hear about the achievements of a stranger, stories from his friends. The men on the back wall with him were steel-faced, betrayed no emotion until Eddie Furlani's daughter, a 7-year-old named Zelma, broke down in tears.
人们在致悼词。在文章中，Charlie 写道听到一个陌生人的成就、他朋友的故事感觉很奇怪。后墙上的男人面无表情，没有流露任何情绪，直到 Eddie Furlani 的女儿、一个叫 Zelma 的 7 岁女孩泪流满面。
The little girl was sobbing. You know [COUGHS] in that sort of deep, heartbroken [COUGHS] deep, heartbroken sob. And her stepmother was kind of bent over and escorting her out through the door. And she is just sobbing. [COUGHS] Again, you can imagine all these 6 foot plus, 300 pound, athletic Navy SEALs. And [COUGHS] [LAUGHS] Everybody just looked so helpless. It was like-- there isn't anything these guys can't take on and win, and here's this little girl sobbing [LAUGHS] right behind us. And there's nothing anybody could do.
那个小女孩在啜泣。你知道 [咳嗽] 在那种深刻、心碎的 [咳嗽] 深沉、心碎的啜泣声中。她的继母弯下腰通过门送她出去。她一直在啜泣。[咳嗽] 再次，你可以想象所有这些 6 英尺多高、300 磅重、体格健壮的海豹突击队队员。而且 [咳嗽] [笑] 每个人看起来都那么无助。就像——没有什么事是这些人拿不下、赢不了的，而这里有个小女孩 [笑] 就在我们身后啜泣。而且什么人也做不了什么。
There was a part of your essay that really struck me. I'm just going to read. You wrote, "The military trains you to separate the emotion from the mission. Eddie's oldest girl Zelma was old enough to understand what was happening, but not military enough to know not to show it." Did you want Zelma to be a little more military in that moment?
你的文章里有一部分真的打动了我。我读一下。你写道，“军队训练你把情绪从任务中分离开来。Eddie 的大女儿 Zelma 足够大，能明白发生了什么，但还不够军事化到知道不该表现出来。” 在那一刻，你想要 Zelma 更军事化一点吗？
[SIGHS]
[叹气]
I don't know what to say to that because that little girl wailing out there in the hallway-- you know, that again, set off a cascade of grief that everybody there had to kind of stuff away.
我不知道对此该说什么，因为那个在走廊里号啕大哭的小女孩——你知道，这再次引发了一场每个人都不得不强忍住的悲伤。
Charlie stuffed the grief away with an old military trick. He focused on accomplishing the mission to deliver the flowers Mark had sent him with.
Charlie 用一个古老的军事技巧把悲伤压下去了。他专注于完成任务，给他们带去 Mark 发给他的花。
It's stupid, and I feel so embarrassed to even admit this, but I mean, that's what I clung to is I need give her the flowers. I clung to that idea that my mission is to give her the flowers.
这很蠢，我甚至感到很尴尬承认这一点，但我的意思是，我坚持的是我需要把花给她。我坚持认为我的任务是把花给她。
Luckily, a voice in Charlie's head-- his wife's voice, he says-- told him that delivering the flowers then was a really bad idea. So he stayed put. It made him deeply uncomfortable, all these feelings for a stranger. He wasn't being military enough.
幸运的是，Charlie 脑海里的一个声音——他说是他妻子的声音——告诉他，现在送花是个非常糟糕的主意。所以他原地不动。这让他感到非常不安，对一个陌生人产生的所有这些感觉。他表现得不够军事化。
You lose a degree of empathy in the military because empathy is not an advantageous skill to have in most-- especially comrade-in-arms fields. Empathy is not a useful emotion to have. And [SIGHS] the fact that I'm sniffling and tearing up is generally thought as weak. Like I said, your empathy centers tend to be atrophied.
你在军队里会失去一定程度的同情心，因为同情心在大多数领域——尤其是在战友领域——不是一项有利的技能。同情心不是一种有用的情绪。而且 [叹气] 我在吸鼻子流泪的事实通常被认为是软弱。就像我说的，你的同情中心往往会萎缩。
Well, I mean, I think that you could also see it as proof that your empathy centers haven't atrophied, that they're actually quite present.
嗯，我的意思是，我认为你也可以将其视为你的同情中心没有萎缩的证明，它们实际上非常存在。
They just come out at the wrong times with odd things, which is--
它们只是在错误的时间伴随着奇怪的事情出来，这——
I guess. Although I think some people would argue that a funeral is the exact right time for it to come out.
我猜是这样。虽然我认为有些人会争辩说，葬礼正是同情心显现的正确时间。
Oh, they're present. Yeah, I know they're there. [SNIFFS]
噢，它们确实存在。是啊，我知道它们在那里。[吸鼻子]
The service finally ended. The chaplain asked everyone not to talk to the family, just proceed outside to the flag presentation. But Charlie ignored these instructions and walked up to Eddie Furlani's widow, eager to give her the flowers, to accomplish his mission at last. When he told her he was there on behalf of his friend, Mark, she brightened and gave him a hug. She told him Mark was the whole reason they'd had a service there in San Diego. He'd arranged everything.
仪式终于结束了。牧师请大家不要和家人交谈，直接去外面进行旗帜交接仪式。但 Charlie 无视了这些指示，走向 Eddie Furlani 的遗孀，渴望给她献花，终于完成了他的任务。当他告诉她他是代表他的朋友 Mark 来的时，她容光焕发并拥抱了他。她告诉他 Mark 是他们之所以能在圣地亚哥举行仪式的全部原因。他安排了一切。
Charlie got back in his car and called Mark to give him a report. And then Mark said something strange. He told Charlie he was relieved to hear there had been so many people at the service.
Charlie 回到车里，给 Mark 打电话汇报。然后 Mark 说了一些奇怪的话。他告诉 Charlie，听到仪式上有那么多人，他感到如释重负。
It hit me almost like touching a light socket. He said, "I'm glad people showed up. I was worried nobody was going to be there." And you get that kind of sinking feeling that you've missed something important. And the next thing he told me was is because of how he killed himself. And-- [SIGHS]
这几乎像触摸插座一样撞击着我。他说，“我很高兴人们来了。我担心没有人会来。” 你会有一种错过了重要事情的沉重感。他告诉我的下一件事是因为他是怎么自杀的。而且—— [叹气]
Eddie had disappeared from home 3 and 1/2 weeks earlier. He'd been missing for about a week before his body was found under a bridge. He had a backpack filled with pictures of his family and his service record. In his essay, Charlie writes about that moment after the funeral when he was in his car talking to Mark, and he finally understood how Eddie had died.
Eddie 在 3 周半前从家里失踪了。在他尸体被在桥下发现前，他已经失踪了大约一周。他有一个背包，里面装满了家人的照片和他的服役记录。在文章中，Charlie 写道葬礼后当他在车里和 Mark 交谈、终于理解 Eddie 是如何去世的那一刻。“这一切突然在我的脑海中汇集。没有提到死因，没有训练事故的新闻报道，悼词中没有提到他生命的终结——藏在黑暗中的怪物，你不敢提起的那个，生怕召唤了他的注意。”
"It all came together in my mind suddenly. No mention of cause of death, no news stories of training accidents, no mention of the end of his life at the eulogy-- the monster that hides in the dark, the one that you don't mention lest you summon his attention."
那是怎么改变了你看待事情的方式，理解了 Eddie 是自杀的？
How did that change things for you, to understand that Eddie had committed suicide?
说实话，我感到头晕。我有身体反应。
I got lightheaded, honestly. I had a physical reaction.
为什么？
Why?
因为对此什么都没有。我的意思是，没有任何相关报道。牧师的祈祷没有谈论——没有人说任何关于它的事情。Mark 和 Eddie 的遗孀——正如我今天早上和她谈话时发现的那样——他们非常害怕，因为他们预计会出现一个空教堂。他们预计没人会来。
Because there was nothing about it. I mean, there were no articles on it. The chaplain's invocation didn't talk-- nobody said anything about it. Both Mark-- and Eddie's widow, as I found out this morning when I talked to her-- they were terrified because they expect to show up to an empty chapel. They expected no one to come.
事实上，海军牧师在仪式开始时确实提到 Eddie 是自杀的。但 Charlie 来晚了，错过了。而且 Charlie 误解了 Mark 对没人会来的担心。Mark 告诉我他担心这一点，但不是因为 Eddie 自杀。更像是这一切发生得太突然了，他不确定人们是否能来。
In fact, the Navy chaplain had mentioned at the start of the service that Eddie had killed himself. But Charlie arrived late and missed it. And Charlie had misunderstood Mark's worry that no one would show up. Mark told me he was worried about that, but not because Eddie killed himself. It was more like it all happened so suddenly, and he wasn't sure people would be able to come.
在我们采访的前一天早上，Charlie 给 Eddie 的遗孀打电话，确保她同意他和我谈论这件事。在那次谈话中，他了解到关于 Zelma 在教堂崩溃的一些事情。
The morning before our interview, Charlie called Eddie's widow to make sure it was OK with her that he talked to me. And during that conversation, he learned something about Zelma's breakdown in the chapel.
她想离开的原因是因为她感到羞耻。她感到羞耻，因为每个人都知道她父亲是自杀的，而且他们觉得她是个坏人。听到这个我感到惊恐。[笑] 我的意思是，在所有 [哭泣] 在所有她想到的事情中，她竟然觉得她父亲去世是因为她自己是这个流放者。而且参加追悼会的所有人，他们都是去支持她的，而她却——我不知道。听到这个我感到惊恐。而且她想离开。
The reason why she wanted to leave is because she was ashamed. She felt ashamed that everybody knew her father had killed himself, and that they felt that she was a bad person. And I was horrified to hear that. [LAUGHS] I mean, of all the [CRYING] of all the things for her to think, that she was somehow this pariah for her father passing away. And that everybody in that memorial service, who was there to support her, and she was-- I don't know. I was horrified to hear that. And that she wanted to leave.
Eddie 在 2012 年离开军队，和 Charlie 同一年。Charlie 说当你回到平民生活时，你会找到工作，你有家人和朋友，但你错过了拥有一个更伟大的使命。
Eddie left the military in 2012, the same year as Charlie. Charlie says when you go back to civilian life, you get a job, you've got your family and friends, but you miss having a greater mission.
你的目标感消失了。你必须进化。但当我听到 Eddie 所做的事情时，我理解了他在那一刻的想法。我想我是在尝试用基本的通俗术语来解释。在自己不知道的情况下，但我也许能设身处地地站在他们几个人中的角度，用——
Your sense of purpose is gone. You have to evolve. But when I heard what Eddie did, I understood what he was thinking in that moment. I guess I'm trying to explain in basic layman terms. Without knowing myself, but maybe I can put myself in a few of their shoes with--
你能谈谈那个吗？
Can you talk about that?
关于什么？
About what?
能够设身处地地站在他们的立场。我的意思是，你能谈谈那个吗？你有意愿谈论那个吗？
Being able to put yourself in their shoes. I mean, can you talk about that? Are you up for talking about that?
[叹气] 对不起，我一直在害怕这个。
[SIGHS] Sorry, I've been kind of dreading this.
你想休息一下吗？
You want to take a little break?
[叹气] 不，我可以继续。
[SIGHS] No, I can keep going.
好的。
OK.
[叹气] 我想说我有勇气去面对这个话题，但我觉得我做不到。我觉得我现在做不到——
[SIGHS] I'd like to say I'm brave enough to take that subject on, but I don't think I can do that. I don't think I can do that right--
那没关系。那没关系。
That's fine. That's fine.
Charlie 自己也有过自杀念头的发作。它们导致他在海军的职业生涯结束了。他在麦克风关掉时告诉了我这件事。他说这里可以谈论。我问他，事后看来，让他对 Eddie 的葬礼耿耿于怀的事情，他感到必须写这篇文章的原因，是因为那可能就是他自己的葬礼吗。但他说是的，不是那样。然后他解释了他为什么要写这篇文章。
Charlie's had his own bouts with suicidal thoughts. They brought his career in the Navy to an end. He told me about it when the microphones were off. He said it was OK to talk about here. I asked him if, in retrospect, the thing that got him about Eddie's funeral, the reason he felt compelled to write the essay, was that it could have been his own funeral. But he said no, that's not it. And then he explained why he wrote the essay.
他说他从做医疗救援飞行的经历中知道，仅仅是直升机靠近的声音就能改善濒死者的生命体征。他说，“我给你写信是因为我想成为某人的直升机声音。”
He said he knew from his time doing medivac flights that the mere sound of a helicopter approaching can improve the vital signs of a person on the verge of death. He said, "I wrote you because I wanted to be the sound of a helicopter to someone."
Dana Chivvis——我们想分享全国预防自杀热线的电话号码。那个号码是 800-273-TALK。800-273-TALK。写那篇文章的 Charlie 请我们说，他把他的文章献给了一个帮助过他的家伙，一个在伊拉克牺牲的海军陆战队员，Richard Gannon II 少校。
Dana Chivvis-- we wanted to share the phone number for the National Suicide Prevention Hotline. That number is 800-273-TALK. 800-273-TALK. That guy Charlie who wrote that essay asked us to say that he dedicates his essay to a guy who helped him, a marine who died in Iraq, Major Richard Gannon II.
我们今天的节目由 Miki Meek 制作。参与我们节目的制作人员包括 Elma Baker、Ben Calhoun、Dana Chivvis、Sean Cole、Whitney Dangerfield、Hilary Elkins、Stephanie Foo、David Kestenbaum、Alvin Melathe、[？Stone？] Nelson、Nadia Reiman、Robyn Semien、Alissa Shipp、Lilly Sullivan、Christopher Swetala、Matt Tierney、Julie Whitaker 和 Diane Wu。我们的资深制片人是 Brian Reed，执行编辑是 Susan Burton。今天特别感谢 Judy Melinek、Wesley Lowery、Melissa Franklin 和 David Morin。
Our program is produced today by Miki Meek. People who put our show together includes Elma Baker, Ben Calhoun, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Whitney Dangerfield, Hilary Elkins, Stephanie Foo, David Kestenbaum, Alvin Melathe, [? Stone ?] Nelson, Nadia Reiman, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Our senior producer is Brian Reed, our managing editor is Susan Burton. Special thanks today to Judy Melinek, Wesley Lowery, Melissa Franklin, and David Morin.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，你可以在那里订阅我们免费的每周播客，或者免费收听超过 600 集的档案。《This American Life》由公共广播交换平台 PRX 提供给公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人 Torey Malatia 先生。我知道离母亲节已经过去一周了，但 Torey 仍然在回味他玩得有多开心。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can subscribe to our free weekly podcast or listen to the archive of over 600 episodes for absolutely free. "This American Life" is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. I know it's been a week since Mother's Day, but Torey is still reminiscing about how much fun he had.
我记得在 Walgreens 店里偷东西，然后在监狱里过夜。
I remember shoplifting from Walgreens and spending the night in jail.
我是 Ira Glass。下周带着更多“This American Life”的故事回来。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of "This American Life."
[音乐 - THE POLICE, "MESSAGE IN A BOTTLE"]
[MUSIC - THE POLICE, "MESSAGE IN A BOTTLE"]
我希望有人收到我的，我希望有人收到我的，我希望有人收到我的瓶中信，耶。
I hope that someone gets my, I hope that someone gets my, I hope that someone gets my message in a bottle, yeah.
我希望有人能收到我的，我希望有人能收到我的，我希望有人能收到我的瓶中信，耶。